welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Boston its chapter 2 gives us the epic
rematch between the losers Club and
Pennywise it is a semi faithful
adaptation of Stephen King's source
novel when it doesn't turn your stomach
it kind of makes you think move among
the jump scares and a shocking gore of
this film's finale it poses some fairly
bonkers concepts ancient rituals mystic
lights that were actually very toned
down from what went down to the book so
I'm gonna explain the insane story
behind this ritual and how it changed
the movies ending from the original book
ending and spoiler warning because I'm
going to be discussing this movie's full
plot in ending and details from the
ending of the book that were not in the
movie okay so it's chapter 2 finds the
losers Club as adults most of them
having moved out of dairy none of them
really remembering the battle with penny
wise as kids only Mike Hanlon remembers
he's now the dairy librarian obsessively
tracking penny wisest inevitable return
and plotting a defense strategy Mike
summons the others back to Derry after
Pennywise resurfaces he Pennywise kills
Adrian melon and meeting with bill Mike
shows him this artifact it's kind of
like a tribal Lantern with cryptic
markings Mike drugs bills drink with in
hallucinogenic toxin he drops the kind
of term that you definitely got to be
careful saying to someone who's tripping
the ritual of chewed so what is this
ritual of chewed so in the novel it the
ritual of chewed is one of the more
specific elements from Stephen King's
imagination in the book Ben as a kid
brings it up as a possible way to defeat
it the ritual itself is this ancient
Himalayan practice in which a shaman
confronts a shape-shifter by according
to young Ben walking up to it sticking
out his tongue and the creature sticks
out its tongue they both bike down on
each other's tongues they tell each
other jokes or riddles the first to
laugh gets banished to another world for
all of eternity but it ends up not going
down this way because it's so silly but
it actually gets sillier the structure
of the novel toggles between two
timelines the losers battle with it as
kids and then their rematch with it as
adults and both timelines climax with a
showdown with its true form a giant
spider in the cavern and the kid
timeline bill gets transfixed by its
dead lights in the movie these kind of
hypnotize the observer allowing young
Bev to see their future selves and know
Stanley's future suicide but in the
novel the dead lights drive you insane
if you look at them in a bills case
they transport him to another dimension
called the macro verse I know
macro verse is a vast empty space with
two occupants the evil entity that they
call it and then an opposing giant
benevolent turtle named in other Stephen
King works michurin there have actually
been a number of turtle Easter eggs
across these two it movies of Lego
turtle in George's bedroom and a turtle
statue in the classroom that adult Ben
visits in Chapter two so in the kid
timeline of the books the ritual of
should becomes a battle of wits between
it and Bill its threatens to trap bill's
soul in the dead lights for eternity and
torture him but Bill hears this godly
voice beyond the turtle encouraging him
to rise above his fear bill says that he
believes in Santa Claus and in
superstitions and the love of his
parents and he repeats his speech
impediment tongue twister he thrusts his
fists against the posts and still
insists he sees the ghosts nailed it and
all this successfully repels it in the
meantime but in the adult timeline both
bill and Ritchie are locked in this
cosmic ritual because as an adult bill
no longer has the youthful optimism he
once did rich he tries to use his humor
Eddy steps forward and sprays as inhaler
using the power of belief to turn it
into poison which does hurt it but it
ends up killing Eddy the sacrifice
rallies the other losers to continue
chasing down the weakened spider beating
it to submission until eventually Ben
ends up stomping on it's exact babies
now in the eighth chapter to film the
ritual of chewed plays out differently
early on Mike and Bill engage in this
hallucinogenic Vision Quest that mike
learn from a Native American tribe that
he met with it's actually similar to the
smoke hole Vision Quest that the losers
participate in in the book so in the
movie we see through drug-induced
visions how it arrived at earth
apparently landing via prehistoric
meteorite at the site of Derry the
entity at that time is depicted as a
shape-shifting shadow manifesting as
this like demonic bird the tribe encoded
this whole history with it on this
Lantern object that might end up getting
Mike tells bill and the others that they
have to recreate this ritual by
recovering meaningful objects that
remind them of their past with Pennywise
and burn them in this Lantern in the
exact spot where he arrived so this
sends the adult losers back down memory
lane where each encounter it in various
terrifying forms bill track sound his
bikes silver from a pawn shop run by
Stephen King Meghan
but he ends up using Georgie's paper
boats Bev finds the love note postcard
in her old home Ben finds the yearbook
page that Bev signed when they were kids
Eddie finds his old inhaler Ritchie uses
an arcade token from a time plane with a
boy that he had a crush on for Stanley
they use the hair net from their
underground Clubhouse to protect against
spiders we're shadow in its final form
which in the movie is a giant spider but
with Pennywise his head and torso change
I kind of like since Bill scars guards
face has been so iconic in this reboot
series so they end up burning their
artifacts in this cavern deep beneath
the niebolt house at the crash site of
its per stork arrival but this ritual
fails
Pennywise his red balloon inflates from
the lantern and reveals it in spider
form and they've realized that Mike had
scratched out one of the sides of the
lantern which depicted ancient Native
American ancestors who tried to confront
the entity but got slaughtered anyway
that Mike tries to reassure them that
it's just because they didn't believe
but the losers did believe his kids and
they can do it again but everyone's
panicking and a scramble devolves into
each of the losers individually
confronting their fears that returns to
the bathroom stall and then out fills
with blood Ben gets buried alive in his
collapsing Clubhouse bill returns to his
flooded basement and he has to drown
Georgi Ritchie and Eddie return to the
three doors of the Knievel's house and
eventually they're able to wear down
Pennywise they dis them they chant you
are the clown until he shrinks down into
this adorable melted doll and dies so
the themes of conquering ones buried
fear remain the same in the movie but
the ritual of should is more direct it's
a literal battle that stays in the
cavern and I guess in the losers own
perspectives rather than some dr.
strange a Dark Dimension
now the epilogue of the movie also makes
some alterations from the novel in the
book the town of Derry is mostly
destroyed in the flood which the movie
avoided I guess for budgetary reasons
Bev and Ben end up together
Ritchie mourns Eddie with another film
alteration revealing a longtime
affection between them Ritchie tearfully
carves their initials together on a
wooden post bill returns to his life as
a novelist and they read Stanley's
suicide letter the movie paints Stanley
suicide is less of a selfish spear
phille Act then I suppose a strategic
resignation with him saying that the
survivors of the losers would all need
to be united to be penny wise and I
guess if he went on living he could
never return to dairy and that would
make it an incomplete 6 out of 7 I don't
know how I feel about that but his
posthumous words did in the movie
with a similar heartfelt tone as spoiler
warning for stranger things season 3 the
posthumous message from hoppers letter
now I love another video that breaks
sounding hidden easter eggs of it
chapter 2 but do you think the movie
should have kept the ritual as a cosmic
mack reverse battle comment down below
with your thoughts follow me on twitter
and instagram at a vas and subscribe to
new rockstars and more breakdowns of
stuff you love and for more slightly
annoying pronunciations of silly words
like Jude Jude Jude
[Music]